the only thing colder than the weather
on the East Coast is the relationship
between President Trump and his former
chief strategist Steve Bannon the
president's lawyers sent a cease and
desist letter to Bannon overnight
threatening imminent legal action the
letter accuses Ben and of making
defamatory statements about mr. Trump
and his family in an upcoming tell-all
book the White House says the president
is furious and disgusted fire and fury
quotes been an accusing Donald Trump jr.
of treason he also says the Russia
investigations path to the president
quote goes right through Paul Manafort
Don jr. and Jared Kushner in Benin's
words they're sitting on a beach trying
to stop a category 5 ship read is at the
White House with more revelations from
the book chip what a morning good
morning you bet this bombshell book by
author Michael Wolfe has caused a
dramatic split between President Trump
and a man who used to be one of his
closest political allies the president
said Bannon only pretends to have
influence to fool a few people with no
access and no clue whom he helped write
phony books and this morning CBS News
has learned Wolf's recorded some of the
conversations calling the meeting
treasonous and unpatriotic Bannon said
the three senior guys in the campaign
thought it was a good idea to meet with
a foreign government inside Trump Tower
with no lawyers that is a ridiculous
accusation White House spokeswoman Sarah
Huckabee Sanders fired back against the
treason charge and pointed to bannon's
60-minutes appearance where he called
the collusion accusation baseless I was
there it's a total and complete farce
Russian collusion is a fog if anybody's
been inconsistent it's been him Bannon
also said Special Counsel Robert
Muller's Russia probe is all about money
laundering their path to trump goes
right through Paul Manafort Don Jr and
Jared Kushner adding that they're going
to crack Don Jr like an egg on national
TV Steve's been a friend of mine for a
long time I like Steve a lot that
friendship seems to have faded on
Wednesday President Trump shot back at
his former strategist saying Steve
Bannon has nothing to do with me or my
presidency when he was fired he not only
lost his job he lost his mind
Bannon took on a
front tone on his Breitbart radio
program where he seemed to defend the
president and avoided addressing the
book the president states is a great man
you know I support him day in and day
out the book paints an unflattering
portrait of mr. Trump who wolf says
didn't want to win the presidency and
assured his wife Melania it wouldn't
happen on election night wolf quotes
Donald Trump jr. as telling a friend
that his father looked as if he had seen
a ghost Melania was in tears and not of
joy a claim disputed by the first lady's
office when dealing with the president
wolf writes that aides said that mr.
Trump didn't read was no more than
semi-literate and was quick to lash out
former deputy chief of staff Katie Walsh
told wolf it was like trying to figure
out what a child wants wolf also cites
the president's vulgar language alleging
that he called Sally Yates a derogatory
term for female genitalia and referred
during the campaign to his now
communications director hope Hicks as a
piece of tail wolf did have significant
access here at the White House Sarah
Sanders admits he had about a dozen
interactions with staff and the CBS News
White House team has seen him here
frequently a lot of people here this
morning are wondering how in the world
this happened under their noses and also
this morning Sarah Sanders the press
secretary has announced that White House
staff will no longer be able to use
their personal phones in the West Wing
Nora all right chip thank you